so far the classification examples we've
talked about have used binary
classification where you had two
possible labels zero or one is in a cat
as an alley cat what if you have
multiple possible classes there's a
generalization of logistic regression
called softmax regression that lets you
make predictions where you're trying to
recognize one of c or one of multiple
classes rather than just recognize two
classes let's take a look let's say that
instead of just recognizing cats you
want to recognize cats dogs and big
kicks so I'm going to call cuts across
$1 class to baby chicks cost three and
there's none of the above then there's
an other or none of the above calls
which I'm going to call cost of zero so
here's an example of the images and the
classes they belong to that's a picture
of a baby chick so the cost is three
chances cross one a dog is cost - that's
a guess that's a koala so that's a none
of the above so that's called zero cost
three and so on so the notation we're
going to use is I'm going to use capital
C to denote the number of classes you're
trying to categorize your inputs into
and in this case you have four possible
classes including the other ordinality
above costs so when you're four courses
the numbers indexing your classes would
be 0 to C minus 1 to capital C minus 1
so in other words would be 0 1 2 or 3 in
this case we're going to build a new
network where the output Slayer has 4 or
in this case the variable capital
alphabet C output units so n the number
of units in the output layer which is
where L is going to be equal to 4 or
more generally is going to be equal to C
and what we want is for the number of
units and alquiler to tell us once the
probability of each of these core
classes so the first node here is
supposed to output or we wanted to
output the probability that is the other
class given G and collects
so output probability there's a cat
given X this will output probability
that is a dog given X that will output
the probability I'm just going to
abbreviate baby-shaped
to BBC so probably on a baby chick
abbreviated BC given the inferred X so
here the output labels my hat is going
to be a four by one dimensional vector
because it now has two output for
numbers giving you these four
probabilities and because probably
should sum to one the phone numbers in
the output Y hat they should sum to one
the standard model for getting a neural
network to do this uses what's called a
Softbank layer in the output layer in
order to generate these outputs let me
write down the map and then come back
and do some intuition about what the
soft Maclin air is doing so in the final
layer in your network you are going to
compute as usual the linear part of the
layer so the capital L that's the Z
variable for the final layer so remember
this is layer capital L so as usual you
compute that as WL times the activation
the previous layer plus the biases for
that final layer now having computed Z's
you now need to apply what's called the
softmax activation function so the
activation function is a bit unusual for
the soft mask layer but this is what it
does first we're going to compute a
temporary variable which we call T which
is e to the Z L so this is a plot
element wise so VL here in our example
ZL is going to be four point one is a
four dimensional vector so T itself e to
the GL does an element-wise
exponentiation T will also be a four by
one dimensional vector then the output
al is going to be basically the vector T
but normalized to sum to 1 so al s going
to e to the Z
l / sum from J equals one through four
because there are four classes of T
subscript I so another way of saying
this is that al is also a four point one
vector and the I've elements of this
four dimensional vector let's vary that
al subscript I this can be equal to GI
over some of GI okay
in case this map isn't clear we'll do an
example in a minute that make this
clearer so in cases map isn't clear
let's go through a specific example that
will make this clearer let's say then
your computer's VL + ZL is a four
dimensional vector let's say is 5 to
negative 1/3 what we're going to do is
use this element wise exponentiation to
compute this vector team so T is going
to be e to the 5 e to the 2 e 2 negative
1 e to the 3 and if you present a
calculator these are the values you get
e to the 5 is 1 4 8 4 e squared is about
7 point 4 e to the negative 1 is 0.4 and
études is 20 point 1 and so the way we
go from the vector T to the vector al is
to just normalize these entries to sum
to 1 so if you sum up the elements of T
if you just add up those whole numbers
you get 1 7 6 points 3 so finally a ll
is just going to be this vector T as a
vector divided by 1 7 6 on 3 so for
example this first node here this will
output e to the 5 divided by 1 7 6 point
3 and that turns out to be a zero point
8 4 2 so saying that for this image if
this is the value of V you get the
chance of it being called 0 is 84
two percent and then the next node
outputs B squared over one seven six
point three that turns out to be zero
point zero four two six four point two
percent chance the next one is e to
negative one over that which is 0.02 and
the final one is etude over that which
is zero point one 1/4 so brother another
point four percent challenge that this
is cost number three which I guess is
the baby chick cost right so there's a
chance of it being called zero cause 1
plus 2 Plus 3 so the output of in your
network a L this is also Y hat this is a
four by one vector where the elements of
this for ball one vector are going to be
these four numbers that we just computed
so this algorithm takes the vector Z L
and AB set to four probabilities that
sum to one and if we summarize what we
just did to map from ZL to Al this whole
computation confusing the exponentiation
to get this temporary variable T and
then normalizing we can summarize this
into a softmax activation function and
say Al equals the activation function G
applied to the vector ZL the unusual
thing about this book activation
function is done this activation
function G it takes as input a 4 by 1
vector and it opens a 4 by 1 vector so
previously our activation functions used
to take in a single real value input so
for example the sigmoid and the value
activation functions input a real number
and output a real number
the unusual thing about the softmax
activation function is because we need
to normalize across the different
possible prism used to take in a vector
of inputs and an opposite vector so one
of the things that a softmax crossbar
can represent I'm going to show you some
examples where you have inputs x1 x2 and
these feed directly to a softmax layer
that has 3
or four or more aqua notes that then
opens why hat so going to show you a
neural network with no hidden layer and
all it does is compute z1 equals w1
times the input X plus B and then the
output a 1 or Y hat is just the softmax
activation function applied to z1
so in this neural network with no hidden
there should give you a sense of the
types of things a softmax function can
represent so here's one example with
just raw inputs x1 and x2 a softmax
layer with C equals V output causes can
represent this type of decision boundary
now this is kind of a several linear
decision boundaries but this allows it
to separate out the data into three
classes and in this diagram what we did
was we actually took the training set is
kind of shown in this figure and train a
cost function and train the softmax
classifier with three upper labels on
the data and then the color on this plot
shows fresh holding the outputs in the
salt bags crossfire and coloring in the
input based on which one of the three
outputs had the highest probability so
you can maybe kind of see that this is
like a generalization of logistic
regression with sort of linear decision
boundaries but with more than two
classes but mostafa call has been just 0
1 the cost can be 0 1 or 2 here's
another example of decision boundary
that a Sakai's classifier represents
when Turing on a data set with three
classes and here's another one right so
this is up but one intuition is that
decision boundary between any two
classes well it will be linear that's
why you see for example the decision
boundary between the yellow and the gray
classes that's or the linear boundary
region purple bird is not lineage and
boundary to the purple yellow is another
limitation boundary but you know is able
to use the different linear functions in
order to separate the space into three
classes
some examples with more classes so this
is example with C equals 4 so that the
dream class and softmax can continue to
represent these types of lineages and
boundaries between multiple classes so
here's one more example with C equals 5
classes and here's one last example with
C equals 6
so this shows the type of things that
softmax also I can do when there is no
hidden there of course you have a much
deeper inner network with X and then you
know some picking unions and more hidden
unions and so on then you could learn
even more complex nonlinear decision
boundaries to separate out multiple
different classes so I hope this gives
you a sense of what a softmax player
what a softmax activation function in a
neural network can do in the next video
let's take a look at how you can train
in your network that uses a software
layer